foreign
[Music]
that pain
made me who I am
I spent a lifetime trying to right the
wrongs of the path
as if fighting crime would bring my
parents back
you actually did it
I can't imagine what you've been through
I love you monkey you lost both parents
in one day
I went back in time to save my parents
but instead
I completely broke the universe
but if you went back and changed the
past this world must die
future
do you know what the symbol stands for
means hope right
I will help you if I thought
you want to get nuts
let's get nuts
[Music]
I have to undo what I did
these scars would have
make us who we are I'm about to go back
and fix them
no that's your tragedy to find you
all right
no matter what we do
We're not gonna be able to fix this no
body died
you're strapped to your parachutes they
were in yours
oh
my God
[Music]